44 he scored in 57 full internationals
jimmy grieves was an instinctive goal
scorer and truly one of the greats of
the game
to this day nobody has scored more top
flight goals in english football he
scored 44 goals for his country in 57
games in an international career that
spanned from 1959 to 1967.
the former striker played for chelsea
west ham and ac milan during his career
but it was for his time at tottenham
hotspur that he will be best remembered
greaves helped the england squad win the
1966 world cup despite famously not
being chosen to play in the final
but his contribution was honored in 2009
when he collected a medal from then
prime minister gordon brown for his role
in the world cup victory against germany
saint gravese ran from 1985 to 1992.
in 2015 jimmy suffered a severe stroke
which left him relying on a wheelchair
he'll be remembered by football fans
everywhere but it is perhaps for an
extraordinary spell at tottenham hotspur
which saw him become and still remain
the club's all-time top scorer with 266
goals
that he'll best be remembered
ender brady sky news